hey everyone this is sarah with
registerednessrn.com and in this video
i'm going to demonstrate how to assess
the axillary temperature in an
infant and of course perform hand
hygiene before beginning
to check the temperature in the infant
we're going to check it via the axillary
route so we're going to place a
thermometer tip
in the armpit of the infant and i've
already placed the little protective
sheath over the thermometer so a normal
temperature in an infant can vary
anywhere between 97.5 to 99.3 degrees
fahrenheit to take the temperature make
sure that you turn the thermometer on
and then you're going to place the tip
of the thermometer deep inside
the fold of the armpit and then you're
just going to put the arm down
and you're going to wait for the
thermometer to beep
to tell you the reading okay our
thermometer is beeping so it is done
and the reading is 99.1
so we would document this and this falls
within normal range
okay so that wraps up this video on how
to check a temperature in an infant and
be sure to check out the other pediatric
videos in this series